[Musik]
hey leute ich stelle euch heute mann
mord vor und zwar trägt den namen clay
soll das mod in dem ort geht es darum
dass ihr kleiner ausgleich geschafft
nicht die kuchen machen könnte und die
dann irgendwo absetzen könnte dann
kämpfen die gegeneinander
also ich zeige euch jetzt mal wie man
die kräfte und was da sonst noch gibt
ihr kraft die in dem ihr unten
claim-blöcke rein tut und darüber cent
dann erhaltet ihr clay soldaten und die
könnt ihr auch decken und wenn ich jetzt
einen klee soldaten unten hin tour und
darüber eine der im spiel vorhandenen
farbstoffen dann erhalte ich bei grün
einen grün soldaten bei gelb einen
gelben soldaten bei orange einen
orangenen soldaten bei die lila rot ein
roten und wenn ich auf den platz wieder
auf tour ein blauen aber man kann sie
natürlich auch so einfach grau lassen so
und dann habe ich ihr schon eine kleine
arena sage ich mal vorbereitet so ihr
platziert die leute auf dem boden in dem
mehrfach mit rechtsklick auf einen blog
macht also so und den anderen hier und
dann kämpfen gegeneinander ich würde
einfach tippen der gelbe gewinnt ich
stehe den geräuschen bisschen im weg 50
euro auf den gelben bus jetzt ja sehr
gut und wenn ihr keinen bock mehr auf
den habt könnt ihr einfach mit
linksklick ihn schlagen dann geht er weg
und ihr habt die leute wieder im
inventar aber das ist nicht alles was
ihr mit dem machen könnt ihr könnt ihr
nämlich auch accessoires geben und zwar
wenn ich jetzt einen stock gebe dann
nimmt er ihn auf und für ihn ein stock
sowie für mich ein holzschwert also erst
deutlich stärke gegenüber den feinden
wenn ihr in einem flins zuwirft zuwirft
kriegt er eine kleine spitze auf seinen
stab und es noch hat noch höheren
angriff wenn im leder zu werft hat er
eine rüstung und seine verteidigung
steigt wolle das finde ich süß jetzt
sieht er aus wie so ein footballspieler
weil er jetzt da diese weißen streifen
hat ich weiß nicht ob das wirklich was
bringt aber wenn er seine gesundheit
schlechtes könnte ihm essen zu werfen
dann fühlt sich die wieder auf wenn ihm
gold zu werft setzte sich eine krone auf
und wenn dann weitere von den grünen
leuten hier sind dann ist er praktisch
der anführer und er sagt hey den und den
dänen greifen jetzt an und die leute die
ihr angreift greifen dann seine kumpanen
auch an
dann kann ich ihnen auch glos dann zu
werfen dann mache ich mal eben
und zwar leuchtet er jetzt im dunkeln
und ich mach mal what time data mit dem
was ich kann ihm clay zu werfen
dann ist der praktischen sanitäter und
kann die toten leute aus seinem team
kann er wieder beleben
ich kann im redstone zu werfen dann kann
er den gegner blind machen sodass denn
nichts mehr sieht und ihn nicht mehr
angreifen kann
ich kann ihm schreiben zu werfen das hat
den grund den vorteil dass er den gegner
in einer schleife zu setzen kann und
dass der gegner dann sich nicht mehr
bewegen kann ihn nicht mehr angreifen
kann und wo und ihr seht jetzt auch er
bewegt sich noch relativ langsam wenn
ich ihm allerdings wird zucker dahin
werfe und er sich bewegt dann läuft er
deutlich schneller
und wenn ich im grab oder hinwerfe dann
nimmt er das auf ist gepunktet und wenn
er besiegt wird fliegt er in die luft
also der hat jetzt alle ausrüstungen die
es gibt und wenn ich jetzt ein hin
schätze ich würde meine lippen der
grünen gewinnt so was ich dort gesehen
habt ihr hat den ersten eine grüne 40
getan also wie bei dem schleim dann
konnte sich der gegner nicht mehr
bewegen und er hat ihnen blind gemacht
also sind ganz praktischer so was man
allerdings noch kräften kann ist wenn
ihr rechts dirt 3 und tutor des
abgehauen und hier soll sind dann kriegt
ihr einfährt und diese pferde platziert
die auch wie egal läuft immer schön weg
so da nehmen wir mal den nie landen die
pferde könnt ihr einfach auch per
rechtsklick platzieren so und die suchen
sich jetzt praktisch gegenseitig und
erst jetzt auf dem pferd und das pferd
bringt eigentlich nur mehr verteidigung
man muss nicht es muss nicht unbedingt
sein dass jetzt der lieder in jedem
kampf gewinnt aber eigentlich hat er
dadurch einen klaren vorteil da scheinen
ja mal schauen wer hier gewinnt berlin
hat gewonnen und wieder raus und es gibt
noch eine letzte option die ihr machen
könnt und zwar wenn ihr rechts clay
links in die mitte sticks und unten rein
tut kriegt ihr ein kleines raptor das
ist für mich besonders
sehr cool denn ich mache das nicht
so wie ich jetzt ein paar schon den
haben sagt sagen und ihr keinen bock
mehr auf die hardware vermittelt
register ein rechtsklick
und alle clay soldaten sind tot
das waren jetzt schon alle sachen die es
in diesem mord gibt man kann sich daraus
noch auch noch ganze arenen bauen und
mit einem knopfdruck in die tore auf und
die kämpfen alle gegeneinander und ich
würde sagen wenn es euch gefallen hat
dann würde ich an der kleine lila eine
tüte uns über einen daumen hoch freuen
einfach wo 1 kommentar ein abo keine
ahnung ich wiederhole mich aber egal ich
hoffe euch hat das video gefallen wenn
ihr fragen habt dann schreibt hier unter
das video ein kommentar der downloadlink
ist in der beschreibung und ich würde
sagen tschüss bis zum nächsten review